stop watch it lost which is just my
whole thesis like you know so many
people listening right out you know if
you're complaining like look if you're
like if you're happy and you've got
student loans that you've got mortgages
and and you work two jobs but you're
happy good the problem is there's so
many millions of people just sitting
around complaining just to set the
record straight if you are listening and
you're complaining then you got to audit
yourself you can't watch house of cards
you can't play ball all day you can't
like go to ballet shows like you got to
work here's the thing your grandpappy
didn't have Instagram and snapchat and
Facebook there are thousands of people
right now making money building
social-media followings and then
slanging other products and they went
from being like a pretty girl or a
good-looking guy to you know making a
hundred thousand a year or being
somebody who was funny in the office to
now making clips on YouTube and making a
million dollars either this is real like
like I'm Matt I'm triple mad cuz
complaining always sucked but
complaining really sucks now because
again our grandparents didn't have the
options we have we live in a 24/7 world
you can make money in your underpants
when you get back home from your
waitress lesson when you have no money
you got one thing your time and that's
what I'm an unwavering on this I'm
unwavering if you're complaining you've
got your time you want to wake up and go
to garage sales there's so much money in
garage sales or make your head spin you
want to wait in line outside of Foot
Locker and flip it god bless
like there's a million ways to do it you
just got to decide
[Music]
Oh
[Music]